I also want to thank the Arnold Saltzman
Institute for co-sponsoring this lecture
series also the School of International
and public affairs
thanks to all them for making all this
possible and thank you especially to Bob
Gervais for coming tonight and - and for
speaking with us I think many of you
already know Bob service is the Adlai
Stevenson professor of international
politics
he's also been the president of the
American Political Science Association I
mean normally introduction to this Cohn
you-you'd rattle off all the other kind
of impressive titles that he's had but I
would think it's more interesting here's
something about you know why he's had
all these titles and the reason I think
was never more apparent than if you were
in this room last Friday this room was
filled with Bob services students his
former students his peers in the
profession not discipline of a science
but history he also even had a former
teacher of his Thomas Schelling the
Nobel laureate and this was on the
occasion of marking his achievement as
many achievements as many contributions
it's the kind of honor that very few
professors are ever lucky enough to to
receive and this one this conference in
his honor was I think even more than
usually on such occasions more than
usually filled with with respect and
affection for Bob and his his many
contributions not just to the field but
to the careers of these particular
scholars and in some cases practitioners
as well a number of them had gone on to
work in u.s. foreign policy now I think
also striking was the many different
fields that are represented they had
divided up this conference into the
different fields that Bob services has
contributed to so it began with
international relations theory they went
on to talk about political psychology
nuclear strategy intelligence analysis
and Bob as was apparent through the day
had made the most fundamental
contributions in all these fields now
for a scholar to contribute to just
one field would have been enough to be
proud you know and to feel that they
really accomplished something so it was
really quite amazing and still is
amazing just to think of all the ways
all these different ways in which Bob
services has contributed to political
science to the way political scientists
try to explain the world but beyond
political science to the way in my own
discipline the way historians try to
narrate the world and explain world
politics in their own way and finally
let me just point out and I think this
is something he'll be speaking to
tonight as well
Bob Dervis is also contributed in
efforts to improve American foreign
policy and explain some of the failings
in American foreign policy and
especially American intelligence he's
done this with the utmost integrity so
much so that some of what he said has
been ignored unfortunately but but
nonetheless it's well worth paying
attention to and so I'm hoping I'm
expecting that tonight and talking about
North Korea and Iran he'll he'll be
sharing some of these insights that he's
had about American intelligence but I
think that if you think of all the
different ways that he's made
contributions international relations
Theory nuclear strategy political
psychology and and so on I think it's
the hard press to imagine anyone who is
in a better position to comment on the
current challenges to American foreign
policy and these two particular
countries in particular so with that I'd
like to welcome Bob Jervis and thank him
for peering here tonight thank you
I thank you Matt it's a pleasure to be
here some ways the question of nuclear
weapons both in the Cold War now do
bring together a lot of the interests
that of mine that Matt talks about in
fact I being born in 1940 some of my
first political memories deal with
nuclear weapons and new and strange
things and I've been puzzling about them
ever since what I want to do is talk
about nuclear weapons in the Cold War in
two somewhat different ways and then
they carry over to Iran and North Korea
that I want to start by talking about to
drill the historiography of nuclear
weapons and the Cold War that is not the
history itself that how he's conceived
of the history and that sort of seems
esoteric especially if you're not a
history PhD student but actually it's
important for how we in many senses we
think about these problems and it
reveals I think something about the
debates on what to do without or toward
Iran and North Korea and why those
debates are very difficult
that's the first thing to note in this
context is I'm talking about nuclear
weapons and the Cold War for the first
part of my talk and that's an
intersection and one question that's
fascinating and contested and I'm not
going to get into much is the
relationship between the two you could
imagine a world of with nuclear weapons
but no Cold War and certainly imagine
counterfactual history of Soviet
American rivalry without nuclear weapons
more broadly historians and political
science differ on how not only on
exactly what role nuclear weapons played
in the Cold War did they stabilize at
destabilizing I'll talk about that later
but how central to the Cold War were
nuclear weapons and we often run them
together but actually saying how
important nuclear weapons were to the
Cold War or to turn that around how
important the Cold War was to the way we
have come to think about nuclear weapons
really are quite is not easy to say and
I know for those who are in the Hertog
program which is in some marvelous
opportunity for those of not only for
you and for those of us who come to you
to talk about it
you know it isn't quite as clear as it
would seem at the outset because I think
we think of them together but remember
nuclear weapons were developed at least
in the US before there was a lot of
thought about the Cold War now there's a
big debate about whether the dropping of
the bombs was related to an attempt to
intimidate Soviet Union I think the
answer is largely no my good friend
Campbell Craig and his co-author read
chenko make the a really ingenious
argument that the Hiroshima bomb was not
related to the Soviet Union the Nagasaki
was it's ingenious as I've told Campbell
I think it's wrong but you know it is
ingenious the whole book the whole book
is ingenious and I think wrong but
yeah at least the arms developed without
the Cold War I think we would have had
nuclear weapons in the absence of the
Cold War eventually and the Soviet
American rivalry I think would have
existed without nuclear weapons might
have taken quite a different form come
back weather would have been more
dangerous but anyway the point is the
two are logically separable and
empirically when you look at a lot of
things and ask the question well what
role did nuclear weapons play in this
crisis and that crisis in that general
outlook it is not it's not clear and
it's a very interesting question that is
really I think not been discussed a
great deal but what I'm going to set
that aside I am gonna look at nuclear
weapons i'ma talk by talking about will
the historiography which is mapping the
terrain of how star Ian's and politicals
eyes have looked at nuclear weapons in
the Cold War yeah I want to make four
basic points starting with the fact that
I mentioned to the first meeting of the
Hertog group the perhaps surprising
degree of continuity between continuity
first of views about nuclear weapons
during the Cold War and then even more
surprising the carryover in views at
least of American analysts about nuclear
weapons during the Cold War and their
views about Iran and North Korea today
that right from the start that is really
the fall of 1945 that is month a month
after the bomb was dropped people who
started thinking about nuclear weapons
and what's fascinating I talked about in
the first chapter
nuclear revolution book is that almost
immediately people staked out two
positions that really continued like a
reveal a red thread through the rest of
the Cold War some people are best
epitomized by my late colleague and was
a friend of mine bernard brodie argued
that nuclear weapons were constantly
revolution in statecraft because of
their enormous destructive capability
and the fact that when countries got a
certain number of nuclear weapons
getting more wouldn't matter a lot other
scholars or other people it was
developed this first in 46 was not a
scholar but something william bordon
who those of you who really know that
details of american nuclear history will
know wharton as the key staff member of
the Joint Congressional Committee on
atomic energy who led the move to
increase American reprocessing and
enrichment facilities in 1949 and 50 and
who led the move to deny to lift the
security clearances of J robert
Oppenheimer fascinating character I
think least I think is still alive I'm
not positive I think matters his story
and you must know all these I think he's
alive he was at least a few years ago
anyway Borden argued no this isn't right
nuclear weapons or weapons like any
other weapon yes they are enormous ly
destructive they're to be taken
seriously but they don't turn things on
their head that is they're not
revolutionary and
as the cold were preceded it isn't as
though all the scholars let alone all
the decision-makers went back and
thumbed the the absolute weapon that
Brody's essays appeared in or there will
be no time the more dramatic title of
Gordon's book most of them even the
scholars were unaware well they weren't
aware of Borden made they knew of the
Brodie essays they became famous but
decision makers of course didn't but
they recapitulated these views with
obviously lots of permutations I think
this is quite interesting
because you know it isn't only is it
that tells us so well people reinvent
the wheel they could have saved their
time rereading those two books that is
partly true but it tells something
either about objective reality or about
habits of at least the American minds
and witches which of those is right is
rather hard to tell because people kept
coming back to these two as different
foundational ideas will be interesting
by the way to see to know more about
what people in other countries thought
the problem is there you know other
scholars in other countries never looked
at it as carefully when the scholars in
Soviet Union obviously couldn't scholars
in Britain in other West European
countries could but you know there
weren't as many of them and they were
influenced by the American debate so we
don't have as much of a good test of
whether this was sort of a universal of
looking at it in these two ways or
whether it's something peculiarly
American you but anyway they this leads
to some specifics that I'll get into in
the second half but the interesting
point for the historiography is the
relative lack of change throughout the
Cold War and into the post Cold War
period now it's a relative lack I don't
care when the detail people did change
the McNamara's views for instance change
number of people's views did change
somewhat but but people did tend to see
the world in one way or another and then
what's particularly interesting is that
after the Cold War you find the
continuity continuing and continuing to
senses first people's views do not
change radically with the end of the
Cold War and the way that surprising
because the end of the Cold War brought
us over time an enormous number of them
Western documents especially in the US
side a large number not nearly as many
the Soviet side and some on China as
well and till the history just we could
be written not in a final way but with
much better documentation and what you
find which this links to might in
political psychology is you find in
documents what you expect to find partly
and so people read the same documents
but they don't read them the same way if
I had more time we could talk about what
historians and political scientists have
changed and why I think that's
fascinating and not only at the level of
gossip but you know I'm gonna put that
aside I'm just gonna make the point of
basic continuity which I think it is is
correct yeah it may indicate we're never
going to settle these views now they're
always going to be legitimate
differences about the role nuclear
weapons played in this and that it's not
only related to the fact although it is
partly related
fact that many of those writing about
the Cold War period now lived through it
and took positions either as decision
makers or itself as scholars at the time
but I think it isn't only that I think
that even people coming to it and knew
tend to cluster around some of the same
questions and come up with their answers
and then as we'll see well just do this
now that that there is high continuity
not complete but high and the people who
are Hawks and I'll use the term hawks
and doves yes they're very simple-minded
but they you know they carry us pretty
far I only have 50 minutes if we had
three hours we break it down but lets us
use the term hawks and doves and then if
you want we can qualify them but anyway
people who are Hawks in the Soviet Hawks
in the Cold War tend to be hawks about
Iran and North Korea Hawks in a duel but
related sense in that they tend triple
sense first they think these countries
are really reaching for nuclear weapons
second and they think if these countries
get nuclear weapons or in the case of
North Korea grow the stockpile
this will lead to really bad things for
the US and Hawks third and that they
think the way we have to deal with this
is with not necessarily force some
things that's not an illegitimate
position but at least by tough
bargaining things people who were doves
in the Cold War who tended to think that
this conflict escalated more than it
needed to through an arms race that was
partly a spiral based on the security
dilemma that is each side inadvertently
making the other side insecure that we
didn't need more than second strike
capability that these people tend to
believe
mmm these country Iran may not really be
going for a full nuclear capability
believe that these countries are
motivated more by security than
aggression and that the consequences of
these countries getting nuclear weapons
are not so bad
full disclosure I am now although was
not always more in the Dove camp on this
both less on the Cold War where Frank
Gavin of when I really have been quite
ambivalent and have moved back and forth
but I am with some ambivalence II in the
death camp Iran and North Korea on that
point just one of them let me just say I
know a conservative conservatives
especially believe that cerebral paalam
that the university world is all on the
left and so we brainwash our students
I'd say the lot the first statement is
largely true on the second statement I
just want to make two points no one who
has ever read student exams can think we
brainwash our students those of you who
are TAS writers and this is relevant
because I've spent some time during the
Bush administration and now arguing with
my former students in the government
that we're following an incorrect policy
these are very very smart people I
admire their work enormous ly I'm proud
that I played some role in their careers
and they're wrong so clearly if I my
attempt to brainwash them has not
succeeded but anyway the main point is
you get this continuity in spite of the
fact that dirty to say the Cold War
continuity in spite of the in large flow
of documents and the post Cold War
continuity in spite of the fact that the
situation's are and the actors are
wildly different
an implication of this is that
persuasion is really difficult and this
is true I think scholarly persuasion and
political persuasion does occur I don't
want to say it's not there but it is
very difficult that especially among
people who look at things seriously that
evidence is always ambiguous and that
we're not going to settle these
questions once and for all one and that
we will econo ''tis in people and
policies but but immediately there is
one puzzle that I really can't answer
maybe you want to come back home
question the answers that oh the Obama
policy toward nuclear weapons is
represented by the Nuclear Posture
review and the New START treaty with
Russia is fairly consistent with his
campaign position he seems to develop
before the policy toward Iran and North
Korea is less consistent and we can talk
about why there is I don't have I have
some speculation don't have a good
answer
third point on the resource of the
historiography is that the current world
affects the past as well as vice versa I
think there's a lot you know that they
say that there is a carryover of views
from the Cold War to the current but my
guess is for some people coming into
this anew for who are the younger
generations that their views on current
issues will affect their reading of the
Cold War that is if you look at people
that scholars or government analysts say
who were just 30 or so that is people
who were too young to have been really
deeply affected by the Cold War era but
my guess is that the views they adopt on
the Cold War will be strongly influenced
by their views of the current situations
in their current policy preferences this
is not new I think we see this all the
time there's a marvelous book by a
historian and Gerald Combs I think the
it's got a very bland titling so like
American foreign policy or something
it's but what it's about I mean you
think who would want to you know is this
just a text book no it's very different
he looks at the interpretations of
crucial elements in American history of
American foreign relations revolution
the war of 1812 foreign policy
surrounding the Civil War the
spanish-american war world war one and
then what he does what's innovative is
he looks at the views that were held at
various generations of scholars and he
argues I think it really shows that the
interpretations of events fifty even a
hundred years earlier or were very
influenced by the debates that were
current where
people were writing and so the
interpretation save the war of 1812 that
were written in 1920 were strongly
influenced by the debates about the
first world war in a way you'd say this
shouldn't happen as historians you know
we're studying the past you know that
the decision makers in in eighteen
eleven and twelve were not influenced by
my unconditional submarine warfare and
other things but you know I didn't lay
our minds work you know that even
historians deeply immersed in the past
or reading with today's newspapers and
we have to take this into account the
final point on the historiography is the
influences that go the other way that
the past and interpretations of the past
influence where we are now one with some
general thing in the specifics in
general say I think the views of people
who live through the Cold War that were
developed in the Cold War induced
mindsets that are carried over those
people for instance who believe that the
West quote one those quotes the Cold War
through a very will a sort of position
believe that that's likely to work with
Iran and North Korea
you know those who doubt that and talk
about what they believe and I think
correctly the number of ways in which
Reagan was actually fairly conciliatory
and that that enabled the Cold War and
those people will say wait a minute
let's look at conciliation in Iran and
North Korea
it comes up in in more specific ways
sometimes can be helpful I guess we CRI
note the more pernicious examples more
Richard Nixon and and others who serve
in the early Eisenhower administration
sincerely believed that American nuclear
threats were very important in ending
the Korean War historian believes that
the question of were they the debate
ranges between the view that they were
totally unimportant and the view that
they were marginally helpful that's
where the Starkel debate is but Nixon
and others believed they were really
very important
this I believe helps explain that his
behavior in Vietnam he didn't make
explicit nuclear threats but as I know
the period understand he did various
things that attempted to show that he
that he might use nuclear weapons that
he was not completely you know in
control of things and variously
similarly I believe you know his nuclear
strategy which I think was not really
crucial to him was affected by his view
that the American nuclear advantage had
been very helpful to Eisenhower not of
you I believe that President Eisenhower
shared Naphtali and fursenko in their
book argued that Khrushchev believed
that Soviet nuclear threats were very
important in getting Britain and France
to halt the attack in Suez and were
important in protecting Iraq two years
later no historian believes either of
those things but if we're to understand
Khrushchev's behavior it's important to
understand the lessons that he
it would be interesting to know how Iran
and North Korea read the nuclear history
of the Cold War you know granted that
countries pay most attention to the
things that affect the most so Iran
presumably pays less attention here than
North Korea North Korea of course was
the target of American nuclear threats
they knew later if not at the time about
the threat and 53 and them in other
threats more implicit I don't know I
doubt given the small size there's a
large community of Cold War dollars at
least dealing with soviet-american
relations in North Korea but you know
it's an important very important
background for them in the lessons they
drew will would be important all right
let me now turn first of the history
battle-ax history of the Cold War and to
the implications for Iran and Iraq and
I'll take about 10 or 12 minutes on each
and ends father I have questions more
than answers
certainly no answers I consider fully
proved but I will try when I do have an
opinion to give them but I do think that
the you know I do want to highlight the
questions the first is an implicit end
question that implies I mean people
haven't written about it as much as they
might and yet I think it's really in the
background a lot of things but it's so
much in background I really didn't think
about it until a couple of days ago this
is how dangerous was the Cold War how
close did we come to nuclear war this is
important partly in the iran/iraq case
and also in our attitudes toward nuclear
payers like Indian Pakistan because and
and the basic question is and it's
related another all raises
how close did we come to war and the way
I like to think about it is were you
know were we lucky were we playing
Russian roulette and you know if you
play if there are enough barrels in the
gun and if we only look say a crises and
not every look at new crises that we've
got really serious we could say there
were a handful I'd you know
crippled how many but let's just say ten
you know well we didn't have nuclear war
does that mean you know he's fun yeah
there were a large number of barrels in
the gun and yeah we spun it and we got
lucky and if we'd done it another 20
times we probably would have had a
different result or does the fact that
we avoided nuclear war at all turn mean
that really this was fairly safe partly
safe because people believed it was
unsafe you know it's a very hard
question and it's just on many levels
one is in retrospect how safe it was and
other was how safe did people think it
was and then related to that what I
alluded to before how to beliefs play
into the interaction
it isn't even entirely clear what we
mean by how safe it was or how close did
we come to war now what does clothes
mean I think what it means is if we
close our eyes and imagine a different
history counterfactuals tweaking small
things would you have gotten war you
know not tweeting up making enormous a
making plausible changes if Nixon had
been elected in 1960 and Khrushchev had
put missiles in Cuba now you might say
women Nixon had been elected
Khrushchev wouldn't have put missiles in
Cuba they're not crazy are they anyway
but let me just assume that he would
would we have had nuclear war that's if
Kennedy had had a slightly different
outlook if there'd been a news leak on
the second day we
you know not unlikely would have
happened if we rerun the history today
because as you know if you know the
history of the crisis the first couple
of days they were tending toward an
airstrike doesn't mean that would have
triggered nuclear war but you know it
would have been different
another way is sort of again just
thinking of more crises let's say they'd
been another six or seven crises how
likely would we've had it's um I think
yeah one goes almost by I got instinct
and I admit I go back and forth on this
I think it was more than luck we did
have a pretty long run of history but as
we know just looking at the Gulf of
Mexico you know having a pretty long
string of cases where you don't have an
oil blowout doesn't mean you never will
the same way having that long string of
not war doesn't mean that you never were
close to war one thing you can also get
on people's beliefs you can look at some
of what people said especially the Cuban
Missile Crisis yeah there problems with
that if you want in the question
the fact that it is so hard I think it
gives more room for people's ideologies
in influencing the answer they give and
I don't mean ideologies pejoratively
people who believe in who worry a lot
about nuclear spread tend to believe we
were lucky people who believe
similarly who worry a lot about I think
North Korea and Iran in particular say
we were lucky and I'll come back to one
part of that so people who were more
relaxed about at least in retrospect on
the cold ward tend to either favor
proliferation and even can waltz who's
written the famous book and it doesn't
really favor it he just says wouldn't be
as bad as you think
tend to be more relaxed here a related
question is did nuclear weapons help
stabilize the Cold War did they reduce
the chances of war or not and this is
again a very hard question because it's
partly counterfactual and what we've
even a political scientists who believe
the chemical additive method would say
well we could compare nuclear with
non-nuclear worlds and we can say there
are a lot more wars in non-nuclear
worlds and do this two ways we can look
at the history of the world of super
power relations rather great power
relations before 1945 and after 1945 you
know the world after 45 is bloody but
the great powers in this case a Soviet
Union in u.s. don't fight each other
before that you get a lot of wars among
great powers I think that statement is
true and I think this is one of the
things that leads me to
unbalanced nuclear weapons do state did
stabilize the Cold War although there
were ways in which it destabilized it as
well and but I think the fact that most
sensible decision makers and all of them
had this degree of being sensible
realized what an utter catastrophe world
war would be meant that they were
conscious to stay far from the brink
even during crises it also meant in a
way in which beliefs can affect behavior
that you got calls self denying
prophecies after a while due to various
for the academic or government in
academic studies most people in the US
not so much less of a Union came to
believe the greatest danger was called
crisis instability with Tom shelling
called the reciprocal fear of surprise
attack that is a belief that what was
really dangerous was crisis instability
abode was really dangerous was if you
had a crisis and either or even worse
both sides believe that striking first
would bring enormous advantages then
even states that wanted to avoid war
would fight because they would see that
whoever struck first could win the war
and whoever waited could be destroyed
that view whether it's right or wrong as
debatable let really drove a fair amount
of American defense policy from the late
50s on it led the u.s. to do various
things to make sure it's retaliatory
force was secure and to do things to
minimize not entirely to zero but to
minimize the degree to which it
threatened the Soviet retaliatory force
and I think those stabilizing factors
were important in crises
in both reducing the number and in
making them less dangerous than they
otherwise would be and this but note
this view doesn't really explain why
there was no war before the Soviets had
second strike retaliatory capability the
Soviets did not get this till we can
debate whether it's 1961 or 1964 the
difference is partly how you read Soviet
submarine launched forces but there's a
long period when the Soviets don't have
second strike capability and yet as my
colleague dick Betts is shown in his
book on nuclear blackmail the u.s.
decision-makers act as though the Soviet
Union does have second strike capability
which is sort of a puzzle but
nevertheless there is a significant
period before this including of course
the famous period of the American
nuclear monopoly and the view I've just
given won't explain why the US didn't
launch a preventive war which as Mark
Trachtenberg has shown American
decision-makers did give serious thought
to but I do think in in many ways
nuclear weapons were stabilizing but
they were not entirely stabilizing as
Frank Gavin points this out in the
recent is article first the very fact
that war that the total destruction
destructans nuclear war led war to be
something everyone in power thought
about all the time that couldn't help
but heighten tensions even if you were
pretty confident of peace it also meant
you were constantly worried on the other
side getting a usable advantage even if
you were not sure what usable advantage
meant and it also meant you tended to
give not worst-case analysis but to
worry quite a bit about worst-case and
to do some things to take to try to
counteract that
it did mean there it did feed to some
extent an arms race a lot of debates
about whether there really was an arms
race and we could come back to that but
it certainly gave a general tension to
the relationship another way in which
nuclear weapons made the situation
affected the situation I don't want to
say destabilized it was it led to a
general concern if not preoccupation
with Domino effects credibility and
reputation and these three things are
linked and I'm running out of time
they're not gonna go into that more
except I'd say that if you think because
of nuclear weapons worse disastrous it
means it's hard to make the threat to go
to more credible that means you have to
say and do a lot of things to increase
the credibility that increases your
concern with Domino effects of various
kinds it increases your desire to look
tough because that's what protects you
we argue I mean of course the Munich
analogy did play a large role here as
well but and other things that vary by
polarity increased the stress on
credibility and Domino nevertheless you
know question would we have had Vietnam
without nuclear weapons which is the
shortcut to that is an interesting
question third question I want to move
quickly with you is one I just going to
raise not answer but but people it's
related to the nuclear revolution but it
cuts it a little differently whether
nuclear weapons really are very special
category by themselves or whether they
should be available for use as any other
weapon is to quote Eisenhower in there
and people I think mine's just somehow
shifted often as fairly decision-makers
without they're fully focusing on it
sometimes they saw them as a weapon and
sometimes they said no these are very
very different final question and that
we confronted Cold War history and then
the relevance for today is encapsulate
some of these what do nuclear what do
you get with nuclear weapons what do
they bring States one thing maybe status
and I do think we tend to underestimate
the role of status and standing in world
politics in Ned LeBeau as a recent
mammoth book that I think goes a little
devarn the other side but but I think
the we do underestimate you look at the
British decision to get nuclear weapons
when during and after the war and it was
really mostly well we're a great power
great powers have the best weapons
available nuclear weapons are the best
Paypal weapons available ergo you know
it really wasn't more analysis than that
I think the French desire to get nuclear
weapons I think was less because they
were afraid the US wouldn't protect them
and more they knew the u.s. had no
choice but to protect them and so they
could stick it in the American eye by
trying to increase their status by
getting nuclear weapons but clearly one
reason nuclear powers wanted it was for
deterrence the basic idea articulated
most fully by waltz in the
non-proliferation that nuclear weapons
may not be good for a lot of things but
they're good for deterrence no one is
going to tack us if we have nuclear
weapons I need to flag another issue
here because it will come up again in
Iran and North Korea and that is not
only the question of the question of
deterring attacks on your homeland but
also extended deterrence that is do they
protect against threats against your
allies something Britain in France and
today the indian pakistan don't really
face but the u.s. really face because
the heart of a lot of the debates in the
Cold War on nuclear strategy can
down to what makes extended deterrence
credible what may what would make it
credible that the u.s. would do the
first use of nuclear weapons because it
could not contain a conventional Soviet
invasion of Western Europe I think when
we look at what nuclear weapons could do
and look at the history and here I'm
just going to give my conclusion without
the evidence because I'm work you know
past time and the evidence is as usual
ambiguous I think it bears out what
theorists like Tom schelling said and
then I elaborated on and that is and
that if you look at the history of the
Cold War nuclear weapons are better for
deterrence than Compellent
that is they're better at keeping the
status quo i convincing the other side
not to do various adventures than they
are to making changes in the status quo
that you want there in that sense much
more defensive than offensive it's
easier to make the threats to react with
nuclear weapons to protect what you have
and to protect your allies than it is to
threaten to use nuclear weapons unless
the other side retracts its position
this is something we debated a lot in
the Cold War because the Hawks said the
American threats of extended deterrence
are incredible Kissinger when he left
office said time and time again I stood
up before the Europeans and said we
protect them how could they believe that
silly thing you know of course we
couldn't first this was irresponsible
Kissinger said this during the Cold War
it was you it was really not a helpful
thing to say whether it was true or not
but luckily I don't think the Europeans
took him seriously then or later so we
were safe but it is was a big debate
that the Hawks said we have to do all
these things to bolster not our direct
credibility but the credibility of
extended deterrence dove said for
reasons I take me a field but in the
book on nuclear revolution that really
extended deterrence is quite robust you
know those the evidence getting
ambiguous partly counterfactuals back to
the question how close we came to
nuclear war I think when we look back
certainly at situations that were crises
or where there were explicit threats we
find nuclear weapons much more helpful
for the defense in the offense just one
case all mentioned the extended Berlin
crisis from 58 to well people debate
when it ended but let's say 60 to
Khrushchev tried to use the threat of
nuclear war delever as a lever to get
the u.s. out of Berlin in fact he did
convince Kennedy them be ready to make
lots of concessions we know this from
the documents Kennedy did not have to
make those concessions interesting about
but he was ready to make a lot of them
if he had to Khrushchev said in fact I'm
going to do things that will force you
to back down or use nuclear weapons
given that choice you're gonna have to
back down well he'd in the end he didn't
do it
why you could say because he was
sensible he wasn't going to take the
first steps that could lead to nuclear
war and he would have had to take those
steps and he didn't for good reason now
you could say that was just luck I don't
know Khrushchev was pretty risky risk
prone and you know if it worked with
Khrushchev I don't worry a lot about a
Kim Jong ye'll of course maybe we should
we're like him John none but no one
knows anything about him so all right
a lot of these debates come up today and
let me take five minutes to talk about
them
first see the surprise in continuity
North Korea you know and I said the
people who were hawks then or Hawks now
partly also North Korea in Iran are
different countries and different
geopolitical space and yet I think of an
end and in the middle levels of
bureaucracy the people were doing one or
not doing the other but the highest
levels I think there is a sort of shared
outlook about both how bad it will be if
these countries get or North Korea's
continued to have nuclear weapons and
about what the US can best do to avoid
that situation
the Hawks believe that North Korea and
Iran both are dedicated on getting to
getting nuclear weapons I mean or
thought you have them and will use them
in ways that will harm American
interests or at least there's a large
and a probability of that that we have
to you know let's take that very very
seriously well will in other words they
say nuclear weapons can do quite a bit
for the country they say first of all
why would these countries want nuclear
weapons unless they were going to get a
lot out of them because it's costing
both these countries a lot in money and
in international opposition so that
shows they must be strongly motivated
they must think there are really very
very large counterbalancing gains more
specifically the Hawks say that nuclear
weapons will allow these countries to
play a much larger role on the world
stage status can be important here and
just as countries pursue it it can be in
the interests of countries to deny other
countries of status that is we may not
want Iran and North Korea to have high
status for obvious reasons
second the Hawks believe in that and
believe the Cold War shows that nuclear
weapons will allow not only status but
more concrete gains gets back to the
question of extended deterrence no hawk
well almost no Hawk expects an
unprovoked attack from North Korea or
Iran on the US first you know those
countries are a long way from an ICBM
and then you know you can say well what
about putting a nuclear weapon in a
freighter and sending it into
American Harbor you know that's
technologically much easier but even if
you do that I mean the people well why
would they do that that you that really
isn't the main argument the main
argument is that if they have nuclear
weapons they will entre dusar undercut
American extended deterrence the
American ability to project force and
protect its allies in the region's
weather will be much less that our
ability to protect China Jimmy uh Japan
most obviously will be reduced hard to
see who else North Korea might threaten
there also is some fear of giving the
selling the nuclear weapons to non-state
actors I think that is really a
secondary concern but it doesn't fit my
scheme of things so I'm going to put it
aside but certainly their concern of
intimidating Japan and of course South
Korea the argument is partly the Kim the
Kim jong-il regime really still wants to
rule all of Korea they did try once they
think that this will allow them to
intimidate South Korea I don't think
anyone thinks that they would then use
this as a shield behind which they could
launch a conventional attack because
their forces although numerous are not
good but that it would allow
intimidation the argument in Iran is
obviously the same with various wrinkles
the obvious wrinkles are here non-state
actors that is would Iran provide
nuclear weapons for Hezbollah and Hamas
usually hear the antral Hawks is no but
they would
Boldin not only Iran but Hezbollah and
Hamas even if Iran didn't intend that
first Iran probably wouldn't end that
but even if they didn't Hamas and
Hezbollah would that be a position to
take tougher actions and go to Iran say
well you're gonna protect us right or
here you've got the nuclear weapons you
know so we're assuming that they're
playing some role and Hezbollah and
Hamas might might believe this so even
if Iran were not emboldened others would
be
I think part of what drive
you know these and I've argued this with
friends and Academy and in the in two
administrations obviously it's there's
no proof I think it is the same argument
we've had in the Cold War and some what
is a continuity in in people's views let
me just sharpen it with the specifics
and at all all stop that if you look at
the film crisis is too strong a word but
tension now in Korea growing out of the
North Korean sinking of the the choe nam
that you know then south korean quartet
I mean I assume that North Korea did
sink it I doubt if it was the tooth
fairy and there are two arguments that
come up one general about views of
confrontations related nuclear weapons
and second nuclear weapons themselves
the first is what is the motive are we
in an action reaction cycle people who
think that we are the doves say look
what happened before Cho now you've got
to go back and I can't go through the
history with you in detail but anyway
they've been with the elections of South
Korea they've been a hard-line
government come to power new government
has renounce some of the agreements
taking a very tough position without
Korea so the North Koreans are
responding to the South Koreans the
Hawks say that isn't what's going on
what's going on are things internal to
North Korea some related to the
succession not the struggle there is no
struggle for succession but they
maneuverings and various aspects of the
succession and is also related to the
fact that North Korea has now nuclear
weapons it's emboldened that the strong
position North Korea would not have done
this I did not have
nuclear weapons when we look at Iran and
my responses that dove is if we didn't
if we just look at North Korean behavior
and we don't know that it has nuclear
weapons so we can't look at the two
nuclear tests obviously we look at their
external behavior can we see a big
change when they have nuclear weapons
and increase their stockpile my answer
is no I just don't think there's a big
change
the Hawks disagree on that you can't
prove it but I think that's a question
on the Iranian tastes there a lot of
important detail that just flag two or
three dealing with intelligence and then
give a basic question then I'll stop the
number of questions I how good can our
intelligence be on Iran as you know if
you followed it all we you know we know
a fair amount partly thanks to the IAEA
inspectors being at Natanz what we don't
know is whether their secret sites that
is whether they are doing enrichment
anywhere else we also don't know much
about the plutonium separation we know
they're building a power reactor reactor
that will produce plutonium that's they
don't really need but we don't know if
they have other secret things
the secret sites are particularly
important because you've read that Iran
has now enough Leu low enriched uranium
to make one or two bombs yes that's true
but you can't make a bomb out of low
enriched uranium you have to make it out
of highly enriched uranium producing
highly enriched uranium is not just a
matter of running the same stuff through
the reactor through the enrichment
facilities at Natanz as they're
currently configured to do this with any
efficiency you have to shut the plant
down replumb it in a way that would take
months how many hard to tell
for maybe more I have to produce highly
enriched uranium and that would give the
world including Israel which of course
is crucial since I think is real will
bomb rather than allow Iran to get
nuclear weapons I'm not saying they
should I'm just saying they will that
gives a lot of what we call timely
warning we would be a lot of time but
that's only true if there are no secret
sites if there are secret sites where
they're doing both low enriched uranium
and highly enriched or they are somehow
smuggling some of the stockpile from
Natanz to the sites where they're doing
highly enriched uranium then we could be
taken by surprise in a way that would be
nasty and this is an extraordinarily
difficult intelligence problem but the
basic question is where I want to close
is what nuclear weapons what they would
get it ran and obviously we don't know
even if I'm true even if my argument
that weapons haven't gotten North Korea
a lot it wouldn't necessarily mean this
would be true for Iran people who argue
that it drastically undercuts American
extended deterrence I think I mean I
meet that argument with to counter
arguments that are related first this
really paints American deterrence is
really very weak and when you work
through the logic I have trouble with
this I've written about this in detail
in my America chapter that was in the
European Journal of IR in the spring of
2003 in a chapter in my American foreign
policy in a new era when I talked about
how I believe that even if Saddam had
nuclear weapons and I thought I believed
the intelligence I thought it was
getting him that he could be deterred
and I think that argument holds for Iran
as well and I go through some fairly
intricate deterrence you know he thinks
that I think things
I won't do that because it's already in
print say you just substitute Iraq Iran
for Iraq and it has changed the last
letter and you got the basic argument
but I do want to first that this
argument that oh my God if Iran gets
nuclear weapons it's going to be all
this dreadful paints an image of the US
is remarkably easy to deter and I don't
find that convincing I would also ask
and I have asked people involved and
some of them have said this is useful in
some have said they've used to they put
it on briefing slides at some times on
is what is what is around what are we
now deterring Iran from that we couldn't
deter them from doing if they had
nuclear weapons because if you're
worried about the UH nuclear weapons
you're saying that Iran is now we are
now successfully deterring Iran in ways
I'm not sure how long that list is about
it was a year 18,000 two years ago or
someone Iran sees some British sailors
you know in the disputed waters
and the Wall Street Journal ran a
typical Wall Street Journal editorial
saying oh my god think what they would
they're doing this thing but they would
do if they get nuclear weapons my reply
is if Iran had done this when they've
had nuclear weapons the Wall Street
Journal would have said oh my god they
can do this because of nuclear weapons
they never would have done something
like that or they'd not have nuclear
weapons it's not amenable to proof but
it is one of the central questions then
finally I stopped why if they're not
gonna be able to push us around
why do they want nuclear weapons I think
they want nuclear weapons partly for
status I think Iran by the way is not
going to go all the way to nuclear
weapons especially if we have if we have
the right policies not sure they'll do
it if they have the wrong policies but
anyways but why do they want nuclear
capability I think they know as we do
what I said from the Cold War nuclear
weapons were more useful than for
deterrence and Compellent they live in
bad neighborhoods as you know the
realists put it and they had been
subject to threats and North Korea's
nuclear threats
they've been subject to threats of the
regime change in the Iranian case they
have been subject to regime change I
think it would be hard in both cases to
be a decision-maker
and say oh well we're perfectly safe
against American attempts to invade or
subvert us if right I think that would
strain credulity credulity and also be
very susceptible your argument hey if we
have nuclear weapons the chances of
American invasion are greatly greatly
reduced the chances of American messing
around our borders a cross-border room
intrusions are not dropped to zero but
they're significantly reduced the
chances of the u.s. playing the gate a
regime change through subversion don't
go to zero but are greatly reduced so I
see the base of basic motive of these
countries as more defensive than
offensive there are rebuttals and I
would give them to some of them to you
but I'm out of time so let me I've gone
on as usual not ten minutes longer than
and wanted to let me just stop here for
for questions and comments
so those who'd like to pose questions
I'd invite you to come to the to the
microphone this is microphone this is
being recorded so so if you could please
come to the microphone I have a there's
more water over here so I'd like to pose
a question you know Bob one of the
things that you're best known for is is
your book on the nuclear revolution I
mean we could talk a bit about you know
what the implications of your argument
are for you know countries like Pakistan
North Korea but you know this a question
that's been on my mind just more
generally about after the Cold War you
know where we stand in terms of the
nuclear revolution especially if the US
and other countries are reducing their
their Arsenal's these weapons are
becoming at least in the case of the
u.s. increasingly antiquated now you
know one basic question would be what
should the goal be you know do you do
you say a lot of nice things about
nuclear weapons in the nuclear
revolution and all the the good they've
done in the world in effect I mean so
I'd be would you be among those who
would say the United States should be
working towards a world without nuclear
weapons and even short of that goal you
know do some of the you know aspects of
the nuclear revolution come into
question when the US and other countries
have greatly reduced Arsenal's so so
where we don't stand on that yeah you
know no I am strongly against the book
I've paradoxical then yes the US would
be much better off if nuclear weapons
and knowledge of them disappear because
we have enormous conventional
superiority we can beat up every anyone
we want with two hands tied behind our
back right I mean just look at the
figures no one can can stand up us now
guerrillas that's the read
and make Afghanistan a democracy but you
know we can do what we need to do so
we'd be much better off if there were no
nuclear weapons but I'm strongly against
the global zero because you can't get
rid of the knowledge of how to make
nuclear weapons almost 50 years ago Tom
shelling had an article on this I think
it was in Daedalus and that talks about
why this is so dangerous because if you
get any crisis each country worries
about the other getting nuclear weapons
and you get back into a version of
reciprocal fear of surprise attack oh my
god they might be developing it or
thinking of developing it we'd better
oh gee they realize we're thinking that
way so that will redouble their efforts
well it has to redouble our effort I
think that is is very dangerous so up
and if Obama when he'd been a student
here had taken my nuclear weapons course
I'm sure he would not have arrived at
this position most you know the Gang of
Four who opposed who say we should go to
zero we know some of them don't believe
it I don't know if all of them don't
believe it but some of them have said in
half private and public things they
don't believe it
I'm happy to say that even the Prague
speech and also in the Nuclear Posture
review Obama has backed away from so how
do the levels matter yeah there's a
degree of which I would start to get
worried I wouldn't worry I could I mean
part of it is you'd have to be able to
really go through the typical wonky so
in the area of stuff in the way that I
used to have to try to do in the Cold
War and thank God I've given up but
certainly we're well above that number
and I gather we were willing to make
cuts in some ways the Russian
we're willing to go deeper and others
and you know and we couldn't agree and
we caught the numbers we got now I don't
think the numbers matter a lot except
symbolically and the symbols aren't
trivial so probably what you want is
eventually the trend down a little more
but you have to go to a lot you do have
to do two other things one does
technically I think you do have to do
the stewardship there's a real technical
debate on how safe the stock pile is I'm
totally first a lot of it's classified
and all I do classified work I don't do
it nuclear area and anyway it's highly
technically you could interview and I
could see all the papers and not make at
her tail out of them so I do what every
we all do in this I listen to the people
who've I felt convincing in the past
like dick Garwin and dick says not to
worry and the dick says not to worry I
don't worry
I believe that stockpile is fine but I
just am taking people's word for it
so but not only do you have to make the
stockpile fine you have to make sure
that military takes the stockpile
seriously and of course gates fired you
know to top people in the airforce on
this thing when they flew the bomber
with the cruise missiles on didn't know
they did it and that's really hard
because it used to be nuclear weapons
we're a fast track in the Air Force and
now right if you're doing with the
nuclear weapons you're a dollar they're
never going to be used you know it's
what you what you do for the the people
who were never gonna get promoted you
know long and you need somewhere to park
them in retirement and that's a real
problem
organizationally how do you take this
and as seriously as it has to be when in
a way you're saying you're never going
to use them not that's a real that's a
real challenge but I do think say we
have the paradox that we'd be better off
without them but we don't want to move
we don't want to move too
okay question from Frank Gavin Bob
thanks that was terrific and I always
learned so much from when I hear you
talk and reading her stuff I go back to
it I wrestle with it and one thing that
I was wrestling with and still wrestling
with and it came out you're talking
comes to through the nuclear revolution
book is this a core question of our
nuclear weapons stabilizing or not I
think you admitted I think I feel the
same way it's I go back and forth on
this one way that I try to think about
it is that maybe it's not the question
of their mere existence or who possesses
them but what people decide to do with
them now obviously they're very related
but connected to that I think your book
there's the two big arguments that you
make one that nuclear weapons are
essentially stabilizing because they're
they help in a defense dominant world
support the status quo is essentially
right for people who use them with those
purposes but when people try to do more
with nuclear weapons than then that then
the sort of simple basic deterrence you
get into problem and where I think that
is a real problem we all think about the
coercive uses of it but I think it's
with trying to extend deterrence and
this is where I actually have some
difficulty with your book and some of
the argued you make you say well you
know in fact extended deterrence has
very very low requirements Soviets
probably believe we're going to use
these things and this is where I'm not
so sure because it's very clear to me
that even in a non-nuclear world
united's the the Soviets understood that
the United States had a great interest
in not being attacked but of course we
know the Cold War was about the u.s.
applying its nuclear umbrella to any
number of contingencies territories
situations that couldn't really remotely
be seen as necessarily core interests
and in fact and that brings up all the
questions that we've talked about before
about questioning our that is a u.s.
serious do they have the resolve do they
have that the will and so I'm wondering
if you could
talk a little bit about and again on
this in terms of extending deterrence
something only the United States really
ever does do you see anything
potentially destabilizing about using
nuclear weapons in that extended
deterrent way in the book in your
statement you said you know there
actually it isn't really problematic I'm
wondering if in fact there are some
places where it could be a problem yeah
I think it's a very important question
for the Cold War and it does carry over
we come out a couple ways one is to
think it say about a contradiction
between my stress on what's on a
structural argument and other arguments
I made both about misperceptions and on
the fact room for variants by individual
decision makers you know someone got
there's a saying which I usually think
this has a lot of wisdom that the first
person to say the world word Hitler in
an argument loses but you know right the
thought experiment Hitler with nuclear
weapons not a pleasant thought you let's
say we're talking I went to Mac's
Raleigh's classroom at the end we
talking about Hitler should have stopped
after honey in 1940 imagine Hitler with
nuclear weapons in 1940 and he certainly
could have held on to what he conquered
and maybe much more so it is susceptible
to differences in decision makers the
reply is well that's true but Hitler
really is a very unusual thank God and
during the Cold War we had I didn't you
know how certain number of presidents to
late in the day me to count them and
first secretaries a fair number and they
didn't
none of them they all not none of them
was highly risk taking and so that we
have some data that people who were
fairly different didn't really do crazy
things but that doesn't mean that the
next time we roll the barrel in the
revolver we're not going to come up with
someone who really doesn't understand
next part of that I think more onyx well
on the Soviet Union also in the Cold War
in retrospect a number of people
including I think condi rice have said
oh well when just find the war in Iraq
and saying in fact Saddam would be hard
to deter if he had nuclear weapons and
people say well you know we deterred Mao
Stalin and Khrushchev etc and she said
yes
but the Soviet Union really was pretty
easy to deter they were actually status
quo powers and sensible well when you
read and here's an elephant an element
of in concerns II what what condi and
others were saying in the Cold War they
were not saying that the Hawks were not
saying that the Soviets were you know
little Pussycats and we didn't have to
worry and God knows Matt and you
stressed this in your I asked Pete talk
about rogues and you know mal right
poster child for roguishness and so I'm
not sure that yeah I do believe that
Soviet Union and even mouths PRC had an
enormous stake in the status quo
and that at least internationally now
you know we know that and that was very
very valuable if you get someone who
doesn't I agree that harder how robust
is extended deterrence to aspects of
Azeri are one the u.s. of course was
deterred quite a bit I mean Dulles of
course is you know an Eisenhower talked
about rollback in the 48 campaign and we
now know thanks to historians like regna
trovich and others that even especially
Truman was really quite serious about
role
can you read Greg's book undermining the
Kremlin cup and Sarah corks new book I
mean you see there's much more American
covert action against so East Europe and
Soviet Union than we believed at the
time and that the American
decision-makers took this more seriously
than we believe
but you also see and it's especially
comes through in the cork book as well
that that there were real restraints on
this the enormous tension that American
decision-makers faced was that oh my God
if covert action really works is the
cause of World War three and that that
power that tension comes home as the
soviets get nuclear weapons and then we
move it even into the hydrogen thing so
the u.s. backs off so the and then of
course it doesn't do anything in in 56
and Hungary and in 50 in 68 at the
Prague Spring so the u.s. is pretty easy
to deter extended deterrence but I agree
it's not clear-cut or rather the
extended deterrence argument works best
when things are clear-cut when you have
a nice map of Europe during the Iron
Curtain literally running right down the
center and for all the debates everyone
is clear on this is yours in this is
ours there's no ambiguity except in the
area that scares people which is of
course West Berlin everything else it
really is quite clear even for Austria
you know that isn't it's neutral it's
quite clear that if you go in there
that's changing the status quo now the
whole world isn't that way that's
absolutely right we couldn't use
extended deterrence to deter North
Vietnam from sending massive
conventional force down the Ho Chi Minh
Trail even before they had the four of
the final invasion in seventy five a lot
of the story of Vietnam is not a
guerrilla war it is conventional
a speck the ventral war we tried to
deter North Vietnam from doing this
Johnson tried in some ways Nixon more
explicitly as those of you who know the
history no it's fascinating story still
very debatable and furthermore it's
interesting what he says about why we
can do it and I mentioned this that's
Friday he says Johnson couldn't do it
what's the difference between Lyndon
Johnson in me that said Johnson didn't
have willpower I have will in spades in
fact I think he doesn't and I think he
says it because he's trying to give
himself touch coverage on it but in any
event let's take him more seriously and
he thinks this is going to work and it
doesn't it shows and this brings up the
two points you make and I think they're
right or three points first here's a
gray area there is a line in Vietnam but
this is partly a conventional invasion
but it isn't entirely so the line
between North and South Vietnam is for
us if you will a wall for the North
Vietnamese it isn't I think you know
they see it as one country they see it
as a partition that's forced on them and
that's temporary it isn't a wall that's
permanent not only it doesn't have
legitimacy it should but it can't last
it won't last so for them it's not clear
for us it is relatedly
what is here the balance of interest and
there's ambiguity balance of interest
with Glenn Schneider was one of my
professors wrote it's not bad if I say
so myself but it's a little little hard
you don't have to be a quantitative us
to say how are we going to
operationalize these things I say we
want in we convinced Khrushchev to back
down in the Missile Crisis yes we gave
concessions but nevertheless I think we
did
largely because our stake was greater
than his state people who disagree say
how do you get that aren't you proving
that by the result his stake was pretty
great in it too
after all Cuba was in some sense
politically not geographia and curtain
he was you know he was no longer able to
protect Cuba as much yeah how do you
know the balance of interest was was on
the American side and what about
different countries reading of it this
is very squishy I think that's right
the balance of resolve has even
squishier first is it the same as a
balance of interest we say no it's got a
bounce of interest component but it also
has a general component of if you will
national will but the Nixon moon shows
how hard it is to demonstrate will one
raise one way he demonstrated will as
the story ends no is he orders a sack on
nuclear alert in the late summer and
fall of a 69 right yeah and not only
doesn't work the Soviet the idea is not
you know the Soviets will pick it up
they'll put pressure they'll understand
what's about they'll put pressure on the
North Vietnamese and he said you know
the orders we do it in a way that is
designed to be only semi secretive we
did it completely in the open it
wouldn't be good because it would
undercut any seriousness if we did it so
well as disguise it wouldn't do any good
right but we did it in a way we were
sure the Soviet intelligence would pick
up what happens this doesn't pick it up
right until the last few days and then
they scratch their heads and what are
they they attribute it I forgot to what
but nothing about Vietnam so you know
communicating well these things are
difficult and especially in areas in
which that are gray
and dick batts argues this partly in the
nuclear blackmail book
so yes extended deterrence is tricky
it's trickier in the post Cold War era
because we don't have the main theater
of Europe with the line and our
commitment to South Korea and Japan
isn't as great partly because you could
say well why should the u.s. care about
South Korea and Japan an interesting
question and especially how would the
North Korean Sea and we can play this
also in the Middle East so yes III agree
that the argument that the u.s. extended
deterrence is robust because the status
quo is clear to everyone and deterrence
is easier than Compellent doesn't work
as well on the other hand what ways on
the other side is that we're not talking
about mutual second strike capability so
Iran and North Korea are never going to
get anything like second strike
capability on the US so that makes it me
more confident in our extended
deterrence but I agree even in the Cold
War the arguments that the people who
argued that American extended deterrence
wasn't robust you know Kissinger made an
Albert wall stood or made it very much
and why all the people who said why we
needed limited options I think they were
wrong and they and I think the Soviets
felt they were wrong and you know that's
pretty clear I think from the documents
but it may have depended on the
particular clarity of the status quo
especially in Europe
last week we heard from the Deputy
Secretary of State Tim Steinberg and he
made two points I wish I'd been able to
well he made two points too you know in
the time that he was here that both of
them I thought might pose problems for
some of the points that you're making
about Iran especially one was that you
know even before we got to talking about
Iran you said that I'm not going to talk
about non-state actors because that
doesn't really fit in my framework when
asked about this the number two person
at the State Department said that if
there's one thing that keeps us up at
night and that should keep you up at
night
it's the the real danger that there are
groups that have the intentions and the
beginning of capabilities to acquire
nuclear weapons
another point though you know that does
go directly to your your arguments is
well you know after the end of the Cold
War
extended turns becomes more difficult
you said that you thought we were unduly
pessimistic about the u.s. ability to
persuade other countries not to develop
nuclear weapons even if Iran does but
his point was that we know with
certainty you know that Saudi Arabia for
instance would need feel the need to
have nuclear weapons they don't
necessarily have to you didn't say this
but they don't necessarily have to you
know develop the full apparatus they
could conceivably obtain them from
Pakistan did you say that yeah well
you're right I wondered if he would say
it but you know imagine a world in which
you have you know multiple nuclear
powers in the Middle East
none of them including Israel with the
fully secured second strike capability
unless they change their command and
control procedures and so on so does
that worry you
and would that change it anyway your
feelings about Iran yeah it's a good
first on the non-state actors yes I
I think some of the I think some of the
worry is exaggerated but even a slight
worry is worrisome I mean life chances
I don't worry about Iran giving nuclear
weapons to Hezbollah or Hamas because I
think they know very well it would mean
the end of the regime their regime I
mean I think if they did it didn't
secret and it wasn't detected there
they're safe but not only gets benefit
if Hezbollah or Hamas used it I think
Israel would destroy Iran I think Iran
would believe that so and we can
question and I don't I'm not I know very
little about this what is the depth of
the Iranian anti Israeli commitment but
it can't be so deep as to put its own
life at risk so I don't think it would
give it could Hamas or Hezbollah steal
it from Iran I doubt that I do worry
that if Iran gets nuclear weapons they
will not put in place as quickly as
possible all the ancillary things they
need that is the command the physical
security the liver you know the locks
the command and control presumably it
would be held by the IRGC not the army
and that's not entirely good news you
know would the other leaders realize
that you know how much you really need
to lock the damn stuff up in many ways
and I would worry a bit about that on
the North Korea the argument is well
they wouldn't give it but they might
sell it to which my response is well
let's just bribe them I think you know
if we think that's what's driving the
North Korean regime why are we doing
sanctions this makes no sense and again
I think survive
is more I think there's we're not gonna
get sanctions it'll pushing the wall so
the selling strikes me is not likely you
can reply well what have they been doing
with Mayan Mar I don't have a clue and
what have they been doing with Syria
what were they doing and the Syrian
stuff is troublesome we know very little
about that we even the government knows
very little if you'd asked me before
this we Israel bombed the Syrian
facility would North Korea do this I
would have said no so I admit this shows
I don't understand North Korea a lot of
things would show that and I don't think
even the US government has a really good
understanding of why North Korea did
that so that's not a non-state actor but
it it is it is troublesome it what about
non-state actors getting it on their own
I worry more I were I think intentions
maybe although I've seen debate on that
but capabilities this isn't easy I don't
think they can do it and I don't think
they're making serious attempts I just
think this is really really hard
Graham Allison over cells I think the
danger and ironically we owe gray M a
great debt because he got on this early
right at the end of the Cold War the
problem of loose nukes and he really
pounded the table and he convinced a lot
of people to take this seriously and he
was right and they did take it seriously
and now I don't take it seriously but I
think he was right at the beginning I
think he's wrong now the chapters in
John Mueller's book atomic obsession in
its earlier articles I think are a
little exaggerated but closer to the
truth
okay honor on this on Iran and the
spread yep and I don't think it's
inevitable if Iran gets nuclear weapons
that others will
after all the countries in the region
have lived with an Israeli nuclear
weapon why can't they live with an
Iranian which is an interesting question
about them and their attitudes and
partly shows you're worried more about
rivals than enemies it's hard for them
to get it but they are taking moves now
that are precautionary the Gulf states
are moving to increase their nuclear
capability and we've seen that Egypt I
think are taking small steps for them to
indigenously produce nuclear weapons is
extraordinarily long difficult and
expensive and I I don't and I think I
don't think they do it but what you said
is exactly right I think the fear is
greatest in Saudi Arabia and I don't
think Saudi Arabia could produce weapons
of its own in any manageable time but it
is the connection with Pakistan and with
China and of course Pakistan and China
as we know I've worked together we know
the parentage of the Pakistani not
centrifuges but of warheads a large
Chinese role here
would they do it with China and Pakistan
do it it's enough to worry about yes I
mean clearly you have to worry about
that and then do you worry about
regional war you know would Iran stand
idly by and watch the nuclear stuff
start to flow into Saudi Arabia I mean
I'm not you know that is that is
dangerous there is a paradox here though
which I've called to the attention my
friends and the government is say yes it
is
which is to the our policy of deterring
Iran is partly built on saying look if
Iran gets nuclear weapons awful things
will happen
saying that somewhat undercuts our
extended deterrence because it's saying
oh my god if you got nuclear weapons we
can't protect our allies well if I'm
Saudi Arabia had listening to this I'm
hearing it
so our rhetorical line may be feeding
some of these fears
I think if Iran gets nuclear weapons we
would certainly have to do things to
reassure the allies maybe explicit and
nuclear bring up promises I don't think
we want a stationed weapons in Saudi
Arabia but there are things I think we
could do that would be reassuring to
those countries on the other hand they
might themselves be dangerous and they
might not be necessary I mean to me they
might not be sufficient and so yes I
think the point about if you will the
second-order consequences are real and
in addition by later pointing to Saudi
Arabia equation what would the Turks do
is an interesting interesting question
and so yes I really would like to get
Iran if I don't even get them out of the
enrichment business I would like to keep
them a year or 18 months away from
nuclear weapons and I
to do that you have to engage in
diplomacy which for reasons I really
don't understand I think we have not
done just one word and then I'll stop
that I think we should really take I
think the Iranian counter proposal about
doing this with the two Latia or the
swap deal in stages was quite reasonable
I think we should have taken that up
I think the Brazil Turkey deal is
reasonable with some conditions the main
one being that Iran cease enriching to
20% I think that's very reasonable and I
have argued to my former students who I
no longer influence that they should
really that's good to put would be good
for us we by significant time and see if
we get a deal and I think that's
particularly important because I think
there is a potential deal with Iran I
think this administration
unlike the Bush administration would be
willing to get a deal where Iran does
some enrichment of Leu in return for not
having a lot of stockpiles of Leu and a
good inspection regime I think this
administration would do that whereas the
Bush administration would not I think
Iran might well take that because the
alternative doesn't look good they could
claim that as a great victory internally
and I think that's what they're focused
on so here is something where I think we
might be able to get a deal if we can
get things going so I think you're it's
a special bore but I think those and I
think it is important to do it I don't
want to be blas about this I think the
second-order consequences would be great
but I don't think we'll get there I mean
I think if I think Israel would attack
Natanz before there would be a bomb so I
don't think we're going to get
and I don't want to see that world but I
think the second order of things won't
arise okay all right well I think that's
all we have time for
thank you Bob Jarvis thank you all for
coming